and to think so many of you were nervous
when disney bought marvel
big hero 6 this is disney's latest
offering and their first go at a marvel
property albeit a rather obscure one
that they adapted incredibly loosely
that said there's still the requisite
stan lee cameo so keep an eye out for
that this movie's got a whole lot of
things going for and since they chucked
so much the original source material
including several members of the actual
team as it existed in the comic books
you really have to give props to disney
and their approach on this thing
primarily what it deals with is a carol
by the name of hero now hiro is a young
incredibly intelligent boy he's about 14
years old but he's already graduated
high school he's a science and tech whiz
and in the wake of a harsh personal loss
he finds himself being comforted by
baymax now baymax is a prototype
personal care robot and he is going to
absolutely steal your heart he's just
adorable and he's lovable and they don't
get into a lot of the the sort of cliche
oh he's becoming more human no his
programming gets a little bit better be
as he interacts more with humans but he
doesn't become more human he stays the
robot he stays focused on his purpose
and i like that i think it's always a
bit of a cop-out when there's like oh
machines are developing emotions and
like well now you just have an excuse to
just write another human character not
on a machine anymore and some stories
earn it but i like the fact that this
didn't go there in all odd way baymax
actually reminded me a little bit of
gertie from the movie moon which is that
he's doing everything he can to be
helpful within the parameters he's been
given so he's kind of got tunnel vision
and he's a little bit sort of handcuffed
in terms of what he's actually able to
do within his main core programming but
he's going to be as helpful as possible
within those parameters as for other
characters the other makeup of this
superhero team are all kids like hiro
they're all a bit older than him they're
all college age whereas as i said he's
about 14 but they're all science was
well almost all but even the one who's
sort of the token team goofball and he's
not he doesn't have the tech skills at
the rest of them he still has a very
creative mind so in the case of all of
them their minds are really their
superpowers much more than the gear and
the tech they come up with that all aids
them but they have developed it or if
they didn't actually build it themselves
they at least thought of what it was
that they wanted to have so their minds
are their greatest power and that's
really great because science in
superhero context has largely been the
realm of villains i mean going all the
way back to lex luthor sort of the
original mad scientist template it's
sort of funny when it comes to comic
books there's this prioritization of
physical strength and this weird notion
that people who use science and whether
it's chemistry or technology or whatever
to augment themselves and bring
themselves up to the level of
superheroes that that's somehow cheating
and that makes them evil that's not at
all how it should be but honestly it's
kind of the comic book trope and comic
book movies have kind of been taking
that on long before marvel just the idea
of someone who's using their brain to
get ahead as opposed to gumption and
daring do and it's nice to get that
change where the fact that they're smart
is awesome i mean this i honestly think
this is going to turn some kids on to
science i mean the science in this movie
is completely ridiculous it's all
fantasy science but it gets you kind of
pumped for wow you can really come up
and just do amazing stuff if you have
the passion and the mind for it it's
also worth noting it's a wonderfully
diverse cast i mean hiro himself is
japanese or at least
somewhat japanese you can tell in his
design and obviously his name but beyond
that we have a we have a fair amount of
diversity in this cast both in terms of
gender and race and that's just nice and
what's also nice is there's no
particular attention drawn to it they're
just yeah this is them they're all smart
is there a problem and that's kind of
what needs to happen to get in better
diversity to work is you don't draw
attention to it you just
do diversity better and just have it be
just have it be normal make that the new
normal and that's what this movie does
the setting is also worth pointing out
everything takes place in this fictional
setting called san franco which as the
name probably implies is a bit of a
mashup between san francisco and tokyo
and so it's got diversity sort of ethnic
diversity just in the setting as well
because it is very much physically san
francisco it's got that the severe hills
and it's got
something like the golden gate bridge
but it there's this infusion of japanese
aesthetic and that sort of look that
bright-eyed neon look of tokyo and it's
a it's a really fun marriage it makes
for some really fun visuals and visually
this movie is stunning the action scenes
especially there's a lot of action in
this this is a proper comic book action
movie let's not mince words about that
this movie's got some really poignant
emotional stuff too as i said hiro goes
through a pretty harsh personal loss
early in the movie and his trying to
come to terms with what happened is
really the heart of the movie and that's
sort of where his relationship with
baymax comes in baymax gets activated
because hiro is in pain and he's doing
everything he can to help hiro get to a
better place and hero's journey oh god
yeah hero's journey i actually said that
anyway that is the main thrust of this
movie and so that does mean that the
rest of the team they get their suits
and whatever that doesn't kick in for a
while because this thing really wants to
get at this teenager's pain and him
trying to work through it and it plays
that very well and the villain factors
into that to a certain extent as well
now the villain might be the one
slightly weak aspect in certain aspects
he's great visually he looks great
though his powers and the technology
that he's using looks very cool and it's
definitely a match for the heroes but i
think the film
ill-advisedly takes a slight mystery
aspect with the with the villain i mean
i guess i should have expected it he's a
guy and a master you don't know his face
so they're gonna play up a little bit of
mystery to that it is
very easy to guess now that said there's
probably gonna be a fair amount of
younger viewers who won't see it coming
but anyone who's a little bit older and
has seen more than five episodes of
scooby-doo can probably figure out what
this character's deal is or at least who
it is what their deal actually is and
sort of getting into the motivations
actually plays very well once the reveal
is done the reveal
it is what it is it was an easy call for
me to make but the motivations and the
way that character plays into hero's own
journey and backstory is actually quite
well done i mean really disney is just
on such a role right now ever since
tangled they have just been this is this
is the new disney renaissance and this
movie it made me happy it it really is
it's a
fantastic time whether you are a young
kid have young kids whether you like
comic books
or just like action movies any of these
things are a wonderful reason to go and
see this movie i do hope they get to
have a sequel so that we can get a
little bit more of the team dynamic as a
whole because as i said the the focus on
this is hero and baymax but that really
is where it should have been for this
particular movie because baymax
oh baymax they used his battery dying
basically as an excuse to have a drunk
scene in a kids movie and it's one of
the funniest things that you will see
all year now superhero stories actually
do have a fairly long tradition in
animation i've talked about these sorts
of movies before animated superhero
movies what is your personal favorite
superhero animated movie whether it is
based off a comic book property like
this or any of the batman animated
movies or something original like say
the incredibles whatever it is that you
think is the best drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it as for
me i'll be back as soon as i can get my
next fix
you